their milk no not regular milk there's
too much sugar and
you know there's there's options these
days we're learning a lot i actually
have a question for danielle did you
actually make
your kids eat off the floor of course
what do you mean of course
it builds up their immune system how
often does dilly boy eat off the floor
first two years you don't have a choice
they're going to do it anyway
i'm learning lessons here because why am
i broken you're so tough how do you
think your parents raised
they just throw a meat on the floor adam
go ahead eat it like a dog
so your kids you have two twins you've
got you've got you've got four kids in
total you've got four kids yeah pat's
about to have a fourth any minute now
literally two three days ago she was due
on the 21st
guys if you want to raise great kids
give
them food and throw it on the floor they
do the throwing for you
you don't need to worry about that buddy
that's going to happen no matter what
but all right
well danielle i cannot wait for the day
where you
are having your first just to see how
you react
because you know everybody reacts to
their first in a different way some are
so overprotective it's like it's crystal
some are just panicking they're worried
about touching them and changing diapers
all i know is some of them haven't you
know lost sleep in
decades oh wow okay when's the last time
you got less than eight hours of
sleepless nights the last time i got
less than eight hours last time you got
eight hours yeah this morning because
we're starting an hour and a half early
oh my goodness can you imagine this
last time this guy got less than eight
hours of sleep was tonight last night
last night well i was up watching trey
young do his thing
yeah 40 46 48 48 points ridiculous
you've got about 500 uh trey young
rookie cards
i believe in the game 70 psa 10 rookie
cards i believe in that guy
so when you've got that many uh this is
this is basketball i know you're more of
a football gal
but uh dallas cowboys go cowboys maybe
maybe not
i grew up in an oilers fan oilers
houston now houston
but pat is a big obviously believer in
in cards and
non-duplicatable assets tremendous and
he's got a lot of cards and he's got
this one card from his guy trey young do
you know who that is
well i guess i've heard of him okay he's
a business
point guard atlanta he's so exciting to
watch about
i mean talk about i mean when was the
last time you had
a cinderella story in the nba we got a
lot of it right now
i mean last year atlanta's just i mean i
just got goosebumps
do you realize anybody that wins this
year is a cinderella story
anybody that wants any of the ford that
wins it's a cinderella slide
any of that that'll win it's a
cinderella clipper i agree this is
probably the best playoffs uh
i've ever seen and there is no like
ridiculous
you know like the face of the league
type of person and the four and the
what do you call the final four you
don't call the final four he's throwing
something he's throwing confidence
exactly yeah so anyways we've got a lot
of stuff going on janet yellen is pissed
off
we have to say she's a little bit
worried about what's going to happen
with the debt matter of fact why don't
we get into it why don't we get into it
with that so
inflation we can have some stories on
inflation here but i want to tell you
what happened this week when i spoke to
arthur laffer
i had arthur lampheron and i asked him i
said what concerns you the most
right i said tell me what you think
about all these all this talk about
inflation you know how prices are up you
know lumber went up it's back down a
little bit you know all these things
that we care about you know
gas all this other stuff you know home
prices for the first time the median
home prices just reached 350 000
page seven that hasn't happened this is
a new record that we have so
inflation is in place i said arthur how
concerned are you about inflation
he says not at all i said why not he
says because the leading indicator of
inflation is gold and gold hasn't moved
goes the same that it's been so i don't
think inflation is an issue
what do you think about the severity or
the real issue of inflation is it real
or is it just
you know something that's going to come
and go so you know one of the worst
areas has been freight shipping costs
what have you
uh we've seen that begin to turn that's
huge that's going to be huge for
companies to have their
supply delivery time start to come down
so that's one of your sources we've
obviously seen commodities turn
i mean copper's down today every
company's biggest
cost item is labor 60 65 percent of
any company in this country is labor
if you have wage inflation you've got a
problem and if you have true wage
inflation then you're going to see it in
gold
just like he said and we don't know what
true wage inflation is or is not until
we refill the labor pool
and we're not there yet you know we've
got 10 states coming off
over the weekend ending their federal
unemployment benefits early
we had two blue states joining the band
these last few days louisiana maryland
two democratic states who crossed the
line would it be considered a blue state
why
i'm talking about their governors oh god
gotcha governor because the governor's
got to sign it and i mean the
government's got to agree your governor
don't agree you're dead
got it okay so we've got the states are
starting to come on board saying uh uh
you're not just going to sit home and
collect checks anymore get your ass back
to work well i mean the chambers of
commerce the small business coalitions
everybody's like
we need these workers yeah we absolutely
need these workers
and so i i think to laffer's point
talk to me after labor day talk to me
after september the 6th when these
unemployment benefits finally exhaust
themselves
president biden himself has miracle of
america said he's not going to re-extend
them
they're just they're too many people who
are like this was a huge fiscal
backfire we didn't need to do this so
the unemployment checks and
all the multiple stimulus yes i mean
people are making double what they would
have made yeah
and i'm not talking look i understand
that everybody needs a workable living
wage i mean i get skewered for this
on twitter but i actually had somebody
on my twitter feed yesterday say if we
have to sacrifice u.s small businesses
so be it and i was like who said that i
was like what
because i well i'm like look if we put
because 39.8 percent of u.s small
businesses are still not
open post-pandemic wait say that again
38.9 of us small businesses
remain closed post pandemic era
in the beginning a lot of them you're
telling a restaurant you can only open
up
25 capacity or 50 capacity but you're
also telling them out of the other side
of your mouth
if you want to get government loans
through the ppp program you've got to
use 75
of the funds for employees and you're
like as a small business owner you're
like well what which is it
i'm not allowed to increase my
employment beyond 50
capacity if i'm joking restaurant owner
but 75
of the loans have to be earmarked for
labor no no go
so as a result we've got the biggest
companies getting bigger and bigger and
bigger because chipotle
or bank of america or amazon god help us
they can all afford to pay up but they
know they're paying up
for a a finite period of time meanwhile
back at the ranch you're sticking it to
small business owners who cannot compete
so you know how much common sense does
it take to know that that's not a good
strategy i just looked at it
now i'm going to send you the story 47.3
percent
that's insane from a couple days ago
our small businesses 47.3 and do we
really want to wake up tomorrow and be
like big box retailer monopoly america
with no culture no soul so that's the
thing
look i started off now hold your horses
i started off at little
little caesar's pizza pizza pizza pizza
and but there was a starting job
and i was a teenager right now teenagers
are having the best
summer since 2008 because they're paying
teenagers 18 bucks an hour
they're like i can do this for three
months asleep are you kidding me
so they're taking these entry-level jobs
teenagers and we're seeing
and and that's fantastic because you
know what we need we need a new
generation of kids who understands that
they need to work
and not dictate the terms of employment
to their employers which we're seeing
a lot of right now because employees
have negotiating power
because there's still so many people who
are on the sidelines so
talk to me after labor day when all of
this goes away is there anything you're
speculating on will you will you foresee
happening
or is it all like i don't know until i
see what happens
well there is a can you go back to that
please go back to the article please
right there 38.9
the data from the opportunity thank you
small business shutdown pandemic nearly
40 percent
the data from opportunity inside shows
that 38.9 small businesses were
closed as of june 2nd
that's insane to me to be thinking about
that how
okay your joe q small business how are
you competing with amazon
you're you don't have a thousand dollar
signing bonus you don't
the the data compiled by small business
marketing service one play is based on
credit and debit card transactions a
business was marked as
close if there was no transactions for
three consecutive days
beginning march first businesses that
conducted all their i mean that's a good
way of doing it i mean if you're not
getting any credit you're not getting
any revenue then you're not open
here's my question if this is 40 38.9
whatever
across the board across the usa that is
the united states okay so
in florida we've been open the whole
time like
are there any you have to realize that
the last year and a half you've lived in
two states we did it right texas and
florida so you don't know any other so
my point is this and our schools were
open so our labor pools were not as
depleted because we didn't force the
moms onto the sidelines
like like the teacher union cities
chicago and la and new york so you've
got a couple million women out of the
workforce as well
who are also going to feed back into the
labor pool after schools reopen in the
fall
they're finally going to be able to go
back to work because they're not going
to be
controlled effectively by teachers
unions who do not advocate by the way
for kids they advocate for themselves
well it's not safe in the get a
vaccination shut up and get in the
classroom and teach
or find a different profession but don't
hold the moms of this country hostage
hmm but by the way just just a crazy
thing on what happened the last podcast
so the last podcast two days ago
whatever was tues was it tuesday or was
it monday
monday that we did uh we showed cole
beasley's tweet
okay on why his uh opinions on vaccine i
won't even get into it so
cole beasley's tweet we read we put the
show beasley
colby's the the football player yeah he
said what he said about vaccine
we put his tweet up on short clips
vitamin short clips
within a few hours it was taken down and
the channel got a strike and our
valuetainment short clips channel
suspended for one week
just because we read his tweet
we read his tweet that we read his tweet
and i said
my dad got the shot my auntie got my
nanny got the shot melvar pops
we talked about the tweet it was taken
down
what's the lesson there but well look
this
the this should not be censorship usa
is what it is but but the point is
that's a little too much but
you can't even have an opinion to say
we're talking to phil heath bodybuilder
tell me what you think about this we're
talking with gerard we're
we're talking with tom basic
conversation so
uh uh uh it's mean we're allowed to be a
self-directed
nation but by the same token if you're
an employer you're also allowed to
dictate the terms of employment
so there are two huge sides to this
argument right now but you
but we have liberty we can do whatever
we want if we don't want to get
vaccinated
fine we're not vac if our employer says
we have to get vaccinated
and you want to keep working for them
get vaccinated it's a
it's a pretty black and white decision
it is a pretty black and white decision
but it's
it's it doesn't seem like it's a one
it's a
a decision that you can have an opposing
argument to
that's what's a challenge right now it
seems like it's a decision that you
either agree with us or you don't
or else you know it's not like hey you
got a
second opinion do you want to get a you
know first doctor is right and this is
what you better do or else it's a little
by the way you know to be honest with
you if you think about it long term
think about
the ramifications of that long term that
is a pretty annoying place to live
if you can't have an opposing idea what
a place to live
look look my second mattress is in
journalism there's something called the
fourth estate there is something called
the obligation to show both sides of the
story
or you're not journalism and then it's
just editorializing
it's just opinions who's doing that
today though who's shown both sides of
the story today
very few yeah i mean so i mean when
bloomberg's not on when bloomberg tv is
off the air and there's some
gold silver infomercial i've got the bbc
on
do you hear about what happened with
mcafee john mcafee yeah that was
i i saw it come out live last night on
bloomberg can you put up his tweet so i
interviewed the guy
uh i don't know do we have a video what
happened when i interviewed the guy or
no
not readily available if you can if you
can find it so i interviewed john
in 2016. i go to his place when i'm
interviewing the guy you know
you've heard this we've heard the story
but yeah that's really yeah i mean he is
like you know your cell phone is built
to spy on you
the cell phone is built to spawn
everything you're doing that's why i
don't use the regular cell phone that
everybody else uses while i'm doing the
interview in the middle of the interview
a guy knocks on the door ky if you just
kind of go through it
is it just click on it see where it is i
mean somebody just
fast forward a little bit to see uh you
should see what happens
i think it's 43 minutes i think you're
ahead of it
go back go back go back go back go back
okay so can you do me a favor put your
finger on the put put the mouse
on that and go there you go go back a
little bit right there click on it and
get the audio
audio and i know the routes that people
take
um if i want to get to um to ecuador
from hong kong the last country in the
world i'd go through is russia you've
got
50 different options by the way look at
the gunners quite small
he's ready he's got a dream where's he
going he's smoking cigarettes um
russia
so um so i you know
it's hard for me to say is it good
is it bad i don't have all the facts and
neither do you and you're positive so
extremely paranoid yet obviously that
happens in every interview daniel always
takes a gun out you know yeah knocks on
the door but the guy was so paranoid you
know as texans
first time ever i went to an interview
with a guy who
greets me he says hey patrick thank you
for coming out just so you know we got
five prostitutes upstairs if you want to
go before you start the interview i'm
like you know what thank you for the
offer i appreciate that mighty generous
of you
yeah you know hey you know you want i'm
like if you wanted this with a smile
happy ending mario and luis were over
there i'm like you know maybe you asked
mario and luis and they're like no no
we're okay thank you for your
hospitality
and there's like m16s ak-47s guns
literally sitting everywhere like
something's up with this he's like a
scarface type of uh
antivirus software guru extremely
paranoid
so inside the weeds and find out how
to the the extent to which we're being
spied on it's going to freak you out
i mean i look i won't even get in a
volvo anymore i'm like oh no
no no no the chinese own it
i don't want to i don't want to be like
i don't want to know that i'm being
spied on
oh you have to realize who this guy
worked for i mean mcafee before
uh starting mcafee he was like a genius
working on what is a kleiner
which one was it he was working at kai
do you remember where he was working at
he was working at
some mcafee was an employee as a
programmer at
by nasa's institute for space studies
from
68 to 70 for the apollo program and from
there he went to univac
as a software designer and later to
xerox as an operating system architect
in 78 he joined computer science
corporation
as a software consultant he worked for
consulting for booze
allen hamilton which you know who worked
for bruce allen hamilton from 80 to 82
and
from 80 while employed at lockheed
mcafee received a copy of brain
the first computer virus for the pc and
began developing software to come back
combat viruses
and then it becomes what it is he sells
it for 100 million dollars
it's now worth 10 20 billion dollars he
sold only 400 million dollars and then
he sends this tweet put this tweet up
put this tweet up he sends this tweet
uh uh uh in the tweet he says this this
is november 30th 2019 says getting
subtle messages from us officials saying
in effect we're coming for you mcafee
we're going to kill yourself obviously
kill you
i got a tattoo today just in case if i
suicide myself i didn't i was wack check
my right arm boom
i mean this is just a little bit weird
when you see some of this stuff
this is not a conspiracy theory
you know this is just here's a guy
that's saying
i would never take my life he sends a
tweet right before go back to his last
recent tweets he sent a tweet prior to
that
go up a little bit go up a little bit
june 16. let me see what's this
june 16. uh the u.s believes i have a
hidden crypto i wish
i did but it has dissolved through the
hands of many team mcafee your brother
is not going my remaining assets are all
seized my friends evaporated through
fear of association i have nothing yet i
regret nothing keep going up
happy father's day great what does he
say nothing in a democracy powers not
powers given not taken but it is still
power love compassion caring here
have to uh no use for it but it is fuel
for greed hostility jealousy all power
corrupts take care which powers
you allow democracy to wield look it's a
little strange
it's a little strange for him to what's
his but along the lines of
the subject of censorship i mean he
could be right here with us talking
about it
if he wasn't not with us anymore exactly
so i don't i don't know look
uh i i get the idea of uh of
trying to like when you're when you're a
parent and you're raising kids you want
to have the right influence on your kids
and sometimes you will as a parent
try to keep a kid away from your uh uh
what do you call it your kid because god
forbid maybe a bad habit
maybe a cousin who's an addict and
you're like listen we don't want to go
party and hang out with that kid because
i don't like you to pick up bad habits
but there is that and then there is you
can watch that
you can't watch this you can read this
you can't do that i mean it's like
come on buddy it's getting a little too
much right now you're gonna give it a
positive argument and then you wonder
why
you wake up ten years later and you're
like why is my kid so rebellious
yeah you know who i love to interview i
love to interview people who completely
disagree with me
i love interviewing people who
completely disagree did he agree or
disagree
he was he was all over the place by the
way a lot of the stuff that he said in
the interview
came true a lot of this stuff on what he
said about facebook
and that wasn't 16. oh yeah yeah a lot
of the stuff that he said came true at
the time people would have called him
cuckoo conspiracy theorists
but a lot of the stuff that he said came
true such as what i mean
you know the fact that uh keep your eyes
uh
this whole model of ads and what
facebook what they're doing they're
reading you they're studying you all
they're trying to do is get analytics
they're giving to the government that's
how they're experiencing that commercial
it is so
powerful that apple commercial where the
guy ends up you know
in his apartment with the zillions of
people and then he
will say this and then he hits the
privacy he's like you can't follow me
anymore that is a powerful commercial
you're right
yeah i've like i've started to take the
extra few seconds to say
you know i'm on a website looking for
information i'm always doing data
research always writing
do you accept all cookies and i've
started taking the time to go no
i don't so yeah well let me ask you pat
since you've
you've literally sat down with this guy
mcafee yeah and he's
let's just say had some ups and downs in
his life but over the
over the last by the way let's qualify
him he's a very weird guy
totally that has to be qualified this is
not a he's a very very weird guy yeah
but he's obviously a genius
he's a genius but extremely many
geniuses are eccentric
do you know why he married his wife have
you heard him tell the story why he
murdered his wife
no but was that with or without the
prostitutes the prostitute the wife was
a prostitute you know why he murdered
his wife
uh no she said he said he gave the best
oh yeah so he's like okay that because
of that i decided and that's what he
says in the documentary so
we have to know that this is a very very
strange guy
but go ahead no i here's my question
dude over the last
i'm not talking about all the great
things he did in his 30s and 40s in the
genus i'm talking about
when there's smoke there's fire just
look at his resume over the last five
years or so since you've done this
interview
right so number one he died in a spanish
jail in spain year old
stomping grounds where he was extradited
to face federal charges so number one he
wasn't even in america
i think when you interviewed him where
was where was he even living in that
nashville tennis uh two hours outside
but wasn't he living in south america
he was all over he was all over the
place he skipped paying taxes
apparently uh um from 2014 to 2018 so
seven years ago
he was involved in this pump and dump
scheme uh with crypto
that only made him a couple million
dollars when you're worth over a hundred
million dollars and now you're trying to
like
do a pump and to make a couple million
hundred million yeah
exactly so when you were there worth a
hundred million if not more
and now you're scheming and plotting to
make a couple million yeah
that's a telltale sign like things
aren't working out
no financially he's not like your name
is not cheap paranoid is not a cheap
lifestyle
if you're everywhere and if you've got
bodyguards around you and all this
ammunition to the point of schizo he's a
little bit on that side so my question
is are you surprised by this it's
obviously unfortunate surprised
that he tweets i would never whack him
surprised that he's at age 75
found dead of suicide i'm surprised by
that
i'm surprised by that because you know
if you were ever going to take your life
you've done so much drugs that at any
point you could have when you're on
drugs
you don't you don't think reasonably
you're like okay it's not worth you so
he's had plenty of chances to take his
own life yes now he's in jail has he
ever been in jail before like
arrested one time because he was accused
of killing his neighbor for
feeding his dogs with poison and his dog
died and he found his dog
dead in the back because the dog would
bark and the neighbor who retired was a
millionaire seduced
i just want to retire and he throws the
meat over his dog eats and dies he comes
and kills the guy
so mcafee ends up running they're
chasing him they get so he's done that's
when he was in south america
he's he's he's had some here look rest
in peace john mcafee i think
whether whether you want to take the
good the bad the ugly he was an
eccentric character that definitely
influenced a lot of people
and it's just a sad ending to a pretty
you know inspiring entrepreneur type
story just with a very sad
what percentage of conspiracy theories
end up being true
oh gosh that's an interesting question
what like you have to realize
all this alien stuff we're talking about
right now like it's normal try doing
that 20 years ago
try doing that 10 years ago all this
stuff that we're talking about aliens
today try doing that 10 years ago
all this stuff about jfk everybody was
you know
okay okay wait i have an opinion on that
the conspiracy theory
in this country the conspiracy theorists
in this country are toxic
i mean i just i gotta lay that out there
but part of the reason conspiracies are
so
hot and prevalent is because of what we
were talking about censorship
if you don't get both sides of the story
you're going to start making stuff up
and you're going to believe whatever
you're told about the other side of the
story and that's what a conspiracy
theory is
you believe what you're told what's a
conspiracy theory to you
define conspiracy theory it is a
mistruth
that populates so what's the difference
between a conspiracy theory and an
opinion
the difference well a conspiracy theory
is meant to
influence your thinking your your
opinion is just
definition pull up the definition one is
meant to influence other people's
thinking and the other is a reflection
of your own thinking
your opinion that's a personal thing
yeah but your opinion you share with
others that's a form
of trying to influence another person
right so go definition conspiracy theory
prior prior to social media you just put
conspiracy conspiracy
theory and then go pull up opinion
let's see what it is a belief that some
secret but influential organization is
responsible for an event or phenomenon
so
you don't that's queuing that's q anon
but i don't think that's true but but
that's not you can't say
but you can't say that i don't even know
what q anon is you can't say that
somebody could say that's you if you say
that's fox news that's cnn cnn said
russia was a
you know real thing for three years and
you come out the dots here's on the
other side that was
would you qualify that as a conspiracy
theory but i don't think most
people think cnn or fox are news
channels
oh you'll be surprised what are you
talking about we may not
we may not we do you look at cnn and fox
as a propaganda machine
i look at cnn and fox as having agendas
and that's not
news okay i do too so what is news to
you
truly both sides of the story telling
both sides of the story what what it's
what the new york times
used to be it's what the wall street
journal used to be so you still don't
put wsj as
news today wsj
has become a little bit more
left-leaning than you would
think but again my gauge is pure and
simple
if you're going to put joe q out there
in his opinion you're going to
say but this person maintains that dot
dot dot
you have to give both sides or it's not
news then it's
then it's opinion a belief that some
covert but inflational organization is
responsible for circumstance or event
how do you not believe that i mean
that's a very realistic
uh thing that has been happening for
centuries that's not i know
type in opinion definition kai opinion
definition
definition of opinion what no no no keep
this keep this go to a new link go no go
to completely
the conspiracy theories are why john
mcafee went nuts i totally agree with
you
i totally agree with you by the way you
start believing when i sat down with
alex jones and we talked i'm like what
are you doing i said you just
you know feeding some stuff that's a
little too much and you're doing it over
and over and over again
so a view or judgment formed about
something
not necessarily based on fact or
knowledge which all of us have them
right we all have opinions right right
but so so now what we
what we categorically figured out based
on what our friends at google say is a
conspiracy theory is
when somebody believes that a powerful
organization or institution is covering
something up
which is obviously which is obviously
never happening this is the ultimate
conspiracy theory
i mean i have friends meaning it's not
real mean q none doesn't exist but i
have friends who have gone
yeah around you you're saying q and on
the band correct okay yeah
well i hope it doesn't exist i mean
aren't they no i hope
me and all my democrat friends we all
just you know eat baby blood and see
no no no no no no no no that's what we
do that's the thing
if if you frame a conspiracy theory as
being
me and all my democratic friends then
then you
give credence to it can't be not dead
naive buddy you cannot beat it
of course no you're making a joke but
it's also that undermines the fact that
there may be some credence
to a story that's being told i'm not
saying it is or not that's not what i'm
saying
by the way that whole story it's a crazy
story but guess what
there's a group of people that believe
some powerful people may be doing
something like that so what are you
going to do
so do you just sit there and you say i
don't know about that i don't know
we shouldn't look into it so what is
what is what is journalism so let's just
say
i'm a journalist i work at cnn fox nbc
abc cbs whatever it is
and the story pops on my uh uh table and
say hey
here's a note i just want you to look
into this here's what's potentially
taking place at this
catholic church should i look into it or
no it's a conspiracy theory
because catholic church is a very
powerful institution organization that's
been hiding something for a while
i shouldn't look into it did you not see
the movie with what was the guy's name
the davinci code not the da vinci code
the other guy that was recently done a
couple of years ago what is the guy's
name that was played the the founder
he was the uh what is the guy's name
that played founder ray kroc's guy
michael keaton uh the news news magazine
yes yes yes
what was it a great movie by the way
with rachel mcadams himself and they're
trying to kind of figure out the cover
okay yeah and then they found all these
should we not look it up
should we not hold the government over
should we look up so
this goes back to your initial question
what percentage of conspiracy theories
are
actually true did you have a number that
you had
probably a very small percentage less
than 10 percent that's
why that's why we look back and we go
wow woodward and bernstein all the
president's men
erin brockovich that's investigative
journalism because they got both sides
of the story and they didn't stop
digging until they got together both
sides of the story or not
okay that's the problem very few outlets
so so what happens if we're not getting
both sides of the story what that makes
it is
everything becomes conspiracy theory
unless if both sides are willing to do
some digging
but we're not willing to do the digging
because god forbid is true
look at hollywood who were they afraid
of digging for the longest time
who was hollywood afraid of digging for
longest time who were they who were they
afraid of oh my gosh we all know what's
going on with guys we can't say harvey
weinstein yeah
you couldn't say anything yeah you
couldn't say anything yeah
there's still another guy that's up to
it and it was endemic and people are
afraid of saying things you know
i had a guy who was a extremely
good-looking guy
okay who worked at ballets with me
extremely good looking guy
he had the green eyes he was six three
he had that little rougher on the edge's
personality he was doing movies we did a
couple of things together
no not like adam no he had a different
personality
that guy adam's not rough around the
edges adam's actually sweet this guy was
like
he tries right no no he's he's got the
look but he's he's not
he's not thank you guys yeah appreciate
it so so sean sean this guy
let's call him sean his name is sean so
that's pretend his name
says his name is shot he said he says to
me he says to me
he says uh i said so how come you didn't
personal hollywood he said i don't want
to talk about it i said tell me how come
you don't personal hollywood he says
because you're in hollywood at the time
you're saying that you're in l.a i'm
trying you know
anyway so he says let me tell you what
happened to me he said this is when i
said no he says one day i'm invited to a
party
with uh uh david the what is the david
something what is the big producer big
uh hollywood name
uh uh is it giffen is it david's david
geffen
anyway something like that he says i'm
invited to this party now he tells me
the story says
i'm at the party i get invited upstairs
with a friend of mine
and he says come upstairs and they go
upstairs and when they go upstairs
he says i've been watching you that's
great awesome i'm thinking about putting
you guys in a movie
it's like great i'm finally being found
he says i'm at my prime i'm like 22 23.
he says but before we do anything i want
to see you guys kiss each other oh
okay two dudes two dudes i want you to
kiss each other
so the other guy is his best friend he's
like
listen bro i'm willing to do the view
we're best friends here bro blood
brothers
take it to our grave and my friend was a
tough guy says
hell no you out of your mind what are
you talking about he said probably gonna
make it hollywood he says come on he
says no i'm out of here he says from
that he says my friend
stayed in the room i left the party my
friend ended up having a career in
hollywood nothing ever happened to me
okay what happened with a friend i would
like i have no idea what happened
well you got look i'm not going to say
names for them i'm just giving first
name on one of them
but this took off so here's the story
okay now let's let's put everything
there was i there
no could that be an absolute lie yes
could it be a uh story made up 100
but if that story is told by 200 other
men i think we ought to give a little
credibility
help fire to something that's going on
there so all i'm saying is
you know to to categorize the there
there are certain words that are being
thrown around right now hey bitcoin is a
scam
no it's not it is a tool right hey
uh such and such is a scam for i used to
sell a lot you sell life insurance right
hey
insurance is scam they never pay up who
says they never pay up well you have to
go
read up to see if they never paid up the
truth is yes
many insurance companies pnc didn't pay
up they will spend so much money to not
pay what
the claim that's there's a business to
not paying a claim on the pnc side do
you know today on the life insurance
side here's
no not on life insurance exactly however
check this out i had a friend of mine
that
had a quarter million dollar policy he
died when he died they investigated they
never paid him the policy
when it came back they said the the
autopsy the the testing that they did
they spent six months investigating this
they found that that the urine was used
was his brothers he was a smoker he uses
brothers urine they never paid on the
policy because he used somebody else's
urine to come out preferred
versus a smoker on the origination of
policy because it was
that's fraud so in contestability class
they never paid it i get it do you know
how much you
did he died within two years he died
within two weeks oh so the two year
contestant
i get it i totally get it check this out
do you know how much insurance
is right now claims that have not been
taken and not not have been called to
insurance carriers meaning someone died
they had coverage
but no one knew about it and that money
is still with the insurance
22 give us 22 billion 22 billion
sitting there sitting there they just
needed that certificate to get a half a
million to get a million to get a
quarterly so look so somebody says well
insurance companies this no
there is the part that they fight claims
but you know the
the conspiracy side everything today if
you say something somebody disagrees
with you it's
that's what i mean by because i'm not
talking about the guys that spout stuff
over and over and over again it's like
dude
chill out relax a little bit right don't
just take everything as a hundred
percent the way i see it is
you give me a claim i say you know what
i don't know
let's look it up what do you think what
do you think what do you think and we
kind of go through it so
i don't know what happened here with our
friend john yeah it just sounds a little
too fishy man
that's all it is oh god this is like
this is like epstein
yeah that's exactly what i'm thinking
right this is a little too let me bring
you a different perspective here
you know we talk about the pros and cons
of social media
you know what social i mean we're in the
digital social media business it's good
like
the fact that we're all just able to sit
here on a podcast and give our opinions
and
there obviously there's some credence
and credibility i don't know what
they're gonna do with this footage right
now
well touche yes but the the reverse
ended it
speaking of conspiracy theories and you
talked about opinions is
now everyone can just get on their phone
and give you their opinion
and you know the cat's out the bag
like anyone can say anything and
anything can go down any rabbit hole at
this point
you know you could be a one person with
one follower
and just start tweeting stuff and
someone else sees it next thing you know
i heard a guy say
it's a slippery slope out there by the
way you're hiding behind everyone's got
power by the way you're not yourself
you're hiding behind the veil of
anonymity keyboard warriors yeah start
some stuff
and you would never say these things to
people to their faces
oh my god ever and and by the way you
know what's a scary thing about going
down the rabbit hole of conspiracy
so i have family members who will tell
me no this is happening
look at no this is happening no this is
happening i am naturally so flipping
skeptical
okay i'm so skeptical with everything
that
that's why i'm a technically i want to
find out i want to do research tell me
did that really happen i don't know
about that i don't believe that i want
to v i want to verify right
yeah there are people who want to
believe
a hundred percent of things that agrees
with their base meaning so you're an
enemy and she tells me a bad thing about
you whether it's true or not i
want to believe it because it makes me
say that you are really a bad person
it's affirming patrick's bias that's a
problem and we have a lot of that in
america on both sides
we posted something on valuetainment
instagram the other day it was a picture
it was basically everyone getting in
line and you had two
options and one was the line for the
uncomfortable truth
yeah and the other line was for
you know fantasyland yeah and like 100
people were in line
yeah for confirmation and nobody wanted
the uncomfortable truth
okay you probably could pull that up on
you know what happened with it on our
instagram is that the one that
what it was just a picture of an image
but it told a big story huh
he posted a picture of albert einstein
on instagram they took it down they said
this is not good
uh what was this they said it wasn't
true
they said it wasn't true you know how
they would censor especially like false
covet claims yeah
like that they did that for the albert
einstein quote that said like uh if you
judge a fish based on how he can climb a
tree
that that that was the post where they
were kind of giving so what's untrue
about that
i guess either it wasn't his quote
so einstein didn't say that that's the
the quote police so now they're on the
literal
you know literacy literary lincoln
lincoln once said don't believe
everything you read on the internet
yeah you can say that i don't know if
you guys know that it's very factual
it's true it's true by the way youtube
we're joking
we're joking this is a joke we're just
joking there was no twitter when lincoln
was live
it's not serious nathan did not tweet
whoever's sitting there just watching
what we're doing
we're seriously joking so i'm i'm i'm a
clinically hyperactive person okay
this is decaf just put that out there no
you do not want to see me on caffeine
i took two and a half years out of my
life to write a book
because the conspiracy theories about
the federal reserve
were so wrong but at the same time it
was an even worse
organization than the conspiracy
theorist made it out to be i'm like no
no no no you got this all wrong
so that that's how deeply i feel
fed up that's how deeply i feel about
debunking
conspiracies is that you get a
clinically hyperactive person to spend
two and a half years
documenting mainly i love that mainly
how dangerous i love the amazon so
people can see the picture so
we're talking about janet yellen being a
dangerous person tell me why
and well she she would go up in front of
congress and she would say i really
didn't understand all that off-balance
sheet
i didn't understand what led up to the
financial crisis i didn't understand
what was happening on bank balance
sheets and i'm like
this is the woman that was that's our
new treasury secretary seriously
when we're when we're at 28.5
trillion in debt by the way i saw sam
yesterday and sam's like what is it 24
25 i said sam where have you been for
the last five trillion dollars in
national debt he's like
oh i missed it and i'm like sam oh that
was good i pulled up the national
pulled up the national debt clock and
he's like you're right it's almost 28.5
billion trillion and i'm like yeah yeah
so what's going on with july 31st
so we have a debt ceiling coming up so
the nation
has an agreed upon limit
in terms of as much as we can borrow as
many treasury bills notes bonds as we
can sell
and once you hit the debt ceiling and
they negotiated this
july of 2019 that picture i sent you
once once they hit the debt ceiling
which is july 31st
2021 yup the treasury can't sell
anything else
no more issuing debt so you have to live
off of what you have
in your checking account basically plus
what's coming into the in
into government revenues until the
democrats and the republicans get
together
and agree upon what republicans are
saying right now is
big spending cuts now adam are democrats
going to agree to big spending cuts
that doesn't seem to be their um agenda
here's your friend
janet yellen right here treasury
secretary janet yellen warns of
absolutely catastrophic hit to the
economic recovery this summer if u.s
can't pay its bills on time i mean
that's a good picture of jenny ellen she
looks good a picture
she looks like mrs magoo who's scared
anyways um
good pick okay somebody understood that
kudos to somebody come here
adam yeah no that's finish your cereal
right put it on the floor for you eat up
worse chemistry
some strong protein in 2011
the the debt of the country was
downgraded stock market went down 17
can you tell me what it would feel like
today at the stock market went down 17
the 10-year bond the 10-year bond yield
fell 100 bases a full percentage point
can you imagine waking up tomorrow and
being like the 10-year yield is
0.47 what excuse me but that's what
happened in 2011 because
the debt fight was so contentious the
republicans were so pissed off about
obamacare
so so mad they had just won the midterms
and right now mcconnell's like i got my
eye on the prize
get out of here let me tell you it's
gonna get very ugly it's gonna get very
ugly very ugly because they're not gonna
agree so
7 31 there's how long do you think it's
going to take till they come up with
so i i did the math because we published
on this yesterday
it looks like the government has enough
money to run probably through
september 20. look congress the house of
representatives after it leaves for
the july 4th break it's in session
nine days after after that in the month
of july before it leaves for
august the whole month the first day
after
the first day after july 31st that there
can be
just set the chills into the children
the first time that there can be a vote
after july 31st which is when the debt
limit is hit
is september the 20th after 6 30 p.m
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
do you have a favorite go back
go back for a second so okay so break
that down if i'm a small business
walk give it to me as if i'm a small
business
july 31st i no longer have money i i
haven't
can issue debt i can no longer get any
more debt okay
i can't do it so now what if i'm a small
business uncle sam goes to the bank and
they're like
sorry you're cut off that's it and i
have only enough cash in reserves to
last two months well
by then the the the treasury
the treasury checking account by then
should be down to about
400 billion dollars 450 billion
well we're running at about 50 billion
dollars a week
right now is our is our burn rate yeah
that's nothing
well it does not last long and then if
you go back and
you go you go back to 2011 go back to
2013. i
loved it then you start to close
non-essential government agencies
i mean we forget the smithsonian is
closed and then you start furloughing
government employees i love this well
this happened in 2017
when uh you know the infamous uh chuck
schumer nancy pelosi meeting with trump
in the office any other they're going to
blame it on you he's like i don't care
blame it on me
they shut it down let me ask you guys a
question by the way 66
of senators in this country are over the
age of 60. yeah
and they're 15 of the population 66
over 16. over the age of 60 in the
center
as a nation demographically speaking are
young or not represented
you know you know why i love this let me
qualify why i love this and i want to
hear your your thoughts and questions
you know why i love this
let me tell you why i love this because
it's forcing the two sides to get into a
room oh
and chop it up you're forced to
negotiate you don't
have a choice mcconnell said of 2011
because
they've all been around forever right
you've got to dust these people off
they're so old
but mcconnell said of 2007 some of my
colleagues in the gop
thought that the debt ceiling standoff
that they should have shot the hostage
he said no no no what we learned is that
it's best
to collect the ransom this is the man
who's going to be negotiating with the
democrats he's not a guy you want to
negotiate with all he wants to do is
use this as a platform for the midterms
okay
guess anybody either of you guess how
many houses
how many seats in the house of
representatives are needed to flip the
senate
back red how many cities how many seats
say the question again
senate what is this what is the house of
representatives
what is the democratic majority oh it's
less than 12 i want to say at this point
wait you're saying one i thought it's
like seven or nine
what is it five okay five well it was
it was a big number just uh just a while
back so it's now five
because that's not a big number though
no it's no this is the most
razor thin majority in the past century
wow that's how little work mcconnell has
to do
they just need they need one what
that's crazy kai look
but i mean and they need one obviously
and joe manchin is like
a faux republican at this point by the
way who wrote the 1.2 trillion dollar
infrastructure bill
wrote it why doesn't he run though joe
manchin
what as for president why doesn't a guy
like that
run yes and see that's the question
that's the thing for all these
conspiracy theories the fact that joe
manchin is the most powerful politician
man of the personality your time
magazine
my opinion the biggest super economy in
the world until china catches up
he's the most powerful person in the
country and what does that say to you
it says that the country is not full of
conspiracy theorists
it's that the moderates don't have a
voice but joe manchin is the poster
child
for democrats and republicans because
he's straight
down the middle oh down the middle i've
heard that somewhere oh so um
there's a show on the youtube channel i
don't know if you guys have heard about
it
but that's why he's so powerful because
but he wrote the infrastructure bill i
love it
he wrote it personally and by the way
back in 2011
another little parallel the spending
cuts that they finally agreed upon
that was just clawing back money from
from funds that had not been spent
that's what this infrastructure bill is
it's like 589 billion
plus in order to get to 1.2 trillion
they're clawing back funds that were
covet
covered relief programs that weren't
spent yeah so that's why the democrats
are losing their minds
they're like no no no we want fresh debt
and jay powell's sitting over it
at the eccles building in the federal
reserve going wait a minute i need i i
need to buy i need stuff to buy here
well let me know i need a treasury
is there any law that can amend the 731
is there anybody that can come up all of
a sudden there's this one
law and rule that we have that they can
come out and say no we can extend it for
another three months or six months or
not
actually already has been okay guys just
bear with me for two seconds i'm getting
in the weeds here go for it
the law dictates well if you're watching
us you're enjoying this smash the thumbs
up if you're enjoying what danielle has
to do to help us with the algorithms and
subscribe to the channel as well go
ahead continue and take notes
um so the law says that the
uncle sam's checking account which is
held at the federal reserve
needs to be back to the balance that it
was on
in in july of 2019 when the agreement
was made
so you've got to run the money down
because you're not allowed to go into
the fight with extra
padding in your checking account you
have to bring it back down to 120 130
billion dollars which is where it was
july of 2019.
mnuchin steve
thinking that there would be all this
fun funding to spend
ran up the balance to 1.8 trillion
dollars
so it's just now it's 600 billion today
so
it's been run down but janet yellen is
technically going into this fight
with three and a half times the
ammunition of what the law
allows but it's because of trump
overspending that she's got this cushion
oh the irony
wow so trump held he helped yellen out
yes absolutely that's hilarious
so there's but there's but that's okay
mcconnell he's he's he's like
i'm i'm fine 50 bill a week
is what what our burn rate that's our
that's our average since the 1st of may
400 billion which is what we have tax
payments and all that yeah so 400
billion so that means so
so let's just say if mcconnell is going
to negotiate mcconnell doesn't want to
negotiate first week of august not the
second week of august not the fourth
week of august mcconnell wants to
negotiate
no congress is not in session in august
congress is closed they're all no matter
what it's september
september the 20th at 6 30 p.m is the
first time that a vote can come to the
floor of the house of representatives
that is the congressional
calendar it's not going to be pretty and
that was why the summer
of 2011 was a [ __ ] show so give me my
friends
sorry give us the good bad ugly give us
here's what ugly looks like
this is what could happen here's what's
the good that can look like they can
come in they can agree they can get out
give us a good battle the democrats can
agree to all these spending cuts
okay cut out the fact which is not
something that's not the remote program
somebody said six trillion dollars in in
in social spending get that
everything bye-bye yep your entire
agenda goodbye
so that way they kiss goodbye at the
midterms or the republicans can hold
their ground
and democrats still kiss goodbye the
midterms
but they're not so best scenario they're
losing midterms
best case if let's put it this way
in a i always i always look at there's
there's a website
um media something where you actually
can put
the source that you're you're looking at
and they they put it on a spectrum
of left leaning right leaning whether
it's an organization a a
publication a newspaper cnn whatever so
you put cnn up there and it's going to
go way left you put
newsmax up there it's going to go way
right so i checked out
the publication and it was smack dab in
the middle okay pull it up
and um it's like media bias something
something
but i i ch so the publications right
smack in the middle
moderate and it was like the republicans
have this midterm to lose it is theirs
to lose because
of the razor thin majority of the
democrats i mean a monkey could swing
five
a monkey could swing five seats in the
house
and mitch mcconnell might be that monkey
again he's already said i'm not
a turtle he's already said that the debt
ceiling fight's not a hostage you're
gonna
you're not gonna shoot the hostages is
that the website allsides.com or
no it's like media bias fact check
google media buys fact check
buy is facts now go put go put cnn on it
just for fun so you put search
yup cnn
left bias where do you see it left bias
these media sources are moderately this
strongly biased towards liberal causes
through story selection and they tell
you how good their fact checking is
oh well they're not biased fact check
and then you can
then you can put new news max up there
complete opposite side
newsmax
questionable source of course that's one
of the more following extreme
extreme consistent promotions put fox
news up there
see fox is going to be fox is going to
be right newsmax no that
newsmax was too extreme right by right
by integrity moderate to strongly biased
towards conservatives how about media
matters type in media matters
never heard of it media not media media
yeah media matters
al qaeda from norway
left bias okay all right guys can i can
i
it's a great report type in drudge
report right
oh my gosh it's going to be like off the
richter scale but i'm curious to know
what it says
right center center bias there you go
right center so they are considered to
be more moderate and more moderate
than fox news i put up this little
channel called valuetainment let's see
where they're at on this so maybe they
get uh
that's going to be like off the right no
way we're in the rain though in the
middle baby
no we have you here as balanced exactly
we're fair and bad look at that there's
a million different
but it's facts and true how to say yet
facts and truth let me let me circle
back here
we're getting a little but all i'm
saying is this this is something to
to bookmark put the link below in the
comments section
chat that's good danielle let me ask you
when you read something or you see
something
go check the source go see what their
agenda is let's get back to
anyways let's get back to helping our
our fellow man and woman out there okay
we got a little wonky here with the
dates and the times and the
and the debates and what might happen
yeah a little too much for you
no no i'm just saying they're we hear
this i want to
tell us what you're worried about we
hear about this every year the debt
ceiling
and we're going to talk about this and
we're now we're good
go ahead the debt ceiling and we're
running out of money and every year it's
like this hostage situation the
government's going to take over
i'm halfway through okay but every year
it's the same
it's uh yeah they figured it out you
know it's kind of like a superhero movie
it's like ah
is the world gonna oh no they saved the
world oh my god is this gonna
uh they figured it out so like what's
gonna be different this time even when
the government shut down in 2017
the only people that are affected were
the government employees that basically
didn't get two paychecks
hey hey buddy this is great news you
know why here's
let me simplify it for you please do as
if you've got it's as if you got a
credit card
that's 10 grand and you're at 9 600
okay and you got 400 left that's
phenomenal stop overspending
i agree i don't think we have a credit
limit i mean what that does is it
doesn't say
problem it doesn't say it's the end of
the world you know what it is a problem
no you know what it says it doesn't say
it's under the world
it says change your habits change your
spending habits that's all it is to me
this is you sas talks money yeah you do
your
your your principles that you talk about
okay that's helped you go from
zeroing cash sleeping on your friend's
bed in colorado how much money did you
have at the time i was broke is the job
you were broke
did you have it you're right you're a
cash millionaire
why are you cash millionaire today
because what what did you change
what did you change well income and and
cash flow but also expenditures and
saving and
the last thing the folks in democratic
parties
stop spending money i will that's the
point this is all this is it's not the
end of the world now we're talking
the whole point with this is what i love
i love that there's a credit limit i
love that there's a limit that's the
best thing that's actually how the real
world is
freaking sick now we're talking yeah
that's the part
last week i'm buying a bunch of art i'm
buying stuff at the new house right
conservative but we're two dog people
and one cat
yeah so we're semi cat i can't
i like that i can't deny that don't try
to label him
i forgive you i forgive you about it but
but
but the point last week yeah so we're
buying all this art right so
generously by the way yeah yeah johnny
dude i can't wait to the
main one showed up today the main ones
showing up this morning i can't no mr
brainwatch i can't wait for that
by the way to everybody that sent the
request to the different people from a
street artist
uh graffiti artists i took all your
recommendations i looked them up i'm
following a lot of those guys and i got
some cool stuff going on
oh i mean i might have a fifth kid if if
my husband would allow me to like nest
and buy art
wow jennifer's like listen the art's on
you i just need to make sure every
jennifer's more the systematic one
so anyway mr mr booth uh danielle's
husband yeah who doesn't
have her first name he's not having a
fifth kid okay i was gonna say you just
you just
admitted you might have a fifth yeah
well we know we're like kids getting fed
food on the floor buddy get get that
discipline you got to be tough but
here's the point one of the credit cards
we're spending the guy says
your car didn't go through i'm laughing
it's so funny when the guy's like
you sure yeah i'm like guess what all
right
the credit card limit has a limit so me
as a buyer have to pay it off and come
back and say let me spend some more so
tell the real world i like that our
government has to pay off their flipping
debt freaking great
women while we've been sitting here it's
like a couple billions
but you know what's crazy here's what's
great here's what it should give the
american people a stroke
because we're paying the damn bill it's
kind of like this let me put it to you
this way
debt per capita debt per tax payer 226
that debt per taxpayer
i would say i'm going to give you the
best example here here's the best
analogy
you rate this analogy zero to ten okay
imagine you have a credit card
imagine you as the parent are working
hard to make the money
you are busting your ass except the
credit
card is in the hands of your kids that's
what's happening
with our government we're the ones
working to pay off the debt and the
credit card is in the hands of our
politicians they're the kids
the kids these people out there like
yeah let's buy another 1.8 trillion
dollars
now you know spending on how to do it
bro that's the point let's cut
these kids off i agree it's enough cut
off
gosh two-thirds are over the age of 16.
so they're kids
spending bad spending this is too much
50 years some of these people have been
in congress and they're still
this bad behavior has gotten in here by
the way just yeah just so you know our
audience
loves when the technical side of daniel
comes out
as crazy as it sounds our audience eats
it up they actually like data yeah they
like hearing it they're like
uh-oh yes let me get that pen out put
their glasses on
right now they're taking notes yes
they're like you want to know why
they're like facts are powerful
yeah facts are much more persuasive than
opinion i am with you
but there is a percentage of the of the
audience that's like where with adam
just break it down so like a basic
people can understand they're there
please leave your email address some
people like soybeans especially if
you're a female
some people like you know just like the
bottom line baby give me the bottom line
here
i like the analogy that you just used
it's gonna be awesome we're making all
the money we're working and the kids aka
the 65 year old politicians
got the credit cards they're going out
to the club spending the last 500 bucks
on bottles
when you got a limit baby so this is
like nancy pelosi she's like i'm going
to do a bottle well
why don't we go into why don't we go
into our stories of california go to
this california store which is on the
last page i believe
newsom says california will pay off
unpaid rent
occurred accrued during corona virus
pandemic
fox news story california pulled off all
the past due rent accumulated by
residents during the coronavirus
pandemic the move would fulfill a
promise to help landlords break even
while giving renters a clean slate
according to reports this week the state
has about 5.2 billion dollars from
federal aid packages approved by
congress to pay out people's rents
which could be enough to cover said
jason elliott senior counselor
to newsome on housing homelessness
what's unclear is whether california
will continue to ban evictions for
unpaid rent beyond june 30th the date
california's evictions
moratorium is set to expire nationally
actually it looks like the biden
administration is going to push it to
july the 31st because our
nationally national which means they're
going to probably extend as well yes
okay so um and why are they extending it
because
our bureaucrats that spend all this
money on their credit card get that
credit card away from them
they couldn't distribute the 47 billion
dollars in rent relief
quickly enough so they need another
month to get the money to the people
these are bureaucrats so any chance
you're moving to california
hell no but wait wait wait there hi
wasn't there a recall wasn't it
google knew some recall
well that went down this chair
to face recall well yeah we had major
williams on here we know what's going on
when is that it's in november no this is
yesterday
this is this is governor newsome will
face recollection just making a second
time in state history that special
election will be held recall state
governor state officials confirm
wednesday that a recall election will
proceed after just 43 people withdrew
their signatures from petitions to
recall
only 43 during the 30-day window
required by state laws as a result
california department
of finance will not begin estimating the
cost of recall including costs of
holding
as it as a special election as part of
its next regular regularly
scheduled election which will then be
submitted to the governor the lieutenant
governor secretary of state and the
chairperson of the
joined legislative budget committee by
august according to a letter outlining
the process okay wow interesting recall
will cost 215.2
million dollars a day that has not yet
been set huh
but this is actually happening this is
what happens in states that close
outdoor
dining this is what happens but he has
to be able to go to french laundry
though he's got to be able to go to the
restaurant you can't stop him from going
there yeah
so bring it back to this uh and that's a
fact unpaid rent
so that's a fact all these people
conspiracy theories that's a fact
so all these people are essentially who
have not been paying rent they have not
the opportunity to work their business
has been closed
small businesses have been closed 40 40
of u.s landlords are small businesses
they're not all big companies
48 percent of landlords mom and pop i am
so they haven't been paying their rent
for a year they're off the hook
free lunch all these renters and then
the government's going to reimburse
these small businesses the landlords
well i mean all the landlords so some of
them
will be big yeah don't go don't don't
push the blackstone button those oh
so who's the big winner in this the
people that just got free rent for the
last year and a half
of course they're the big winners i mean
stories are proliferating about people
gaming the system
huge surprises we're getting free rent
the non-workers the the people that are
now
maybe they were working maybe they were
not working i don't know that's not how
this thing works
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait okay
there's a little bit of math here right
yeah 300
a week in supplemental unemployment
benefits right so
supplemental that's that's on top of
what your state was giving you yeah
yes so but 1200 a month give or take the
average rent in america is
1600. so your stimulus your benefit from
the government
was way bigger than what you were
getting for sitting on your ass and not
working
way bigger think about that say those
numbers again your stimulus was big
rent nationwide sixteen hundred dollars
that extra three hundred dollars a week
twelve hundred dollars the rental thing
was a bigger stimulus package
do you understand yeah 100 because your
rent is 1600.
so the other one is 1200 so 1600 you're
not paying the rent so you got another
times 18
months essentially it wasn't one time
exactly 2800
right every month and by the way the
lifts are coming quicker
because the gig workers are pouring back
in let me ask you a question let me ask
you a question you said who who pay the
price
let me take a different angle on this
and and i want to hear your thoughts on
this so check this out
so during bad times desperation
okay when a person is desperate you got
two different types of people
the guy that's a worker who's always
wanting to work and improve
is he going to work during bad times
let me ask a question one more time hear
me out kai adam pay attention to what
i'm saying hear me out what i'm saying
during great good times during bad times
good times great times
the guy that's constantly a worker a
hustler creative
innovative wants to constantly improve
whatever his situation is
does he do that during bad times yes
does he do it during good times yes
does he do it during great times now
watch this the guy
that's always trying to find a way a
shortcut to avoid work
doesn't want to watch if you give him
the easy way out he's always going to
take it
does he work during bad times he'll know
no he'll take this does he
work during good times maybe does he
work during great times
it's all one big question the point is
if you allow
him to not work and take a shortcut to
kick back he will always take it and if
you allow
the worker the innovative the creative
guy to work he will always take that
option what percentage of america is
which is why during the pandemic the
rich got
so much richer and the poor got poorer
very simple not because of the shutdown
or any of that stuff it's because
during covet when we did a i did a video
a year ago i said let me let me put it
to you this is what's going to happen
right now
there's going to be those during covet
that are going to get destroyed and it's
the majority
they're going to get destroyed okay
because they're going to be like oh it's
not my fault oh i can't believe what
happened oh i can't believe this
then there's going to be the people in
the middle that nothing changes which
means they stay the same they just
survived they're like i'm a survivor i'm
a survivor it's just surviving for the
rest of their life
all they do is as long as they survive
they're good then there's the there's a
go there's a folks that are going to be
like dude are you flipping kidding me
i'm going to go light it up right now
and they did
not a little bit a lot of it look what
happened microsoft is officially two
trillion dollar company now right
a lot of wealth was made the last 12
months so when you ask the question who
paid the price
who won here and we say oh the people
that got the the stimulus and the rent
and all that stuff they didn't win they
lost because their habits just
officially got even
worse and it's officially in the next 12
months their habits are going to be
what is that one thing you put that
magnificent magnify it's going to be
magnified in ways that we've never seen
we will see we we we're up to
unfortunately
we're back up to 580 000 um homeless in
america
it's it's a tragedy it's it's been
rising since 2017.
so we're going to see homelessness rise
and we're going to see
people who lose everything who don't
want to work
get really mad remember three and three
and nine
kids have been helped by their parents
adult children have been helped by their
parents
during this pandemic record numbers of
adults are living
with their parents i mean these people
they to patrick patrick to your point
when you know in your bones
the dignity and reward from working
you can never not work you'll always do
something
but if you don't know that in your bones
you've just destroyed a member of
society
you've just taken a [ __ ] out of the
economy you've just destroyed future
economic output
by taking away the dignity and the
reward from work
that that that just that just drives me
insane to think about the fact that
a simple common sense principle like
that
is not understood by a complete side
it's like oh it's unfair
let me give the statistic that she just
gave this a fox business story as well
three out of ten parents 33 percent
three out of ten three out of nine
parents are supporting their children
financially during the pandemic
31 say they think they're supporting
their children
more now than they did before covet
according to a new study of bank of
america while nearly one-third of
parents told bank of america
that they've been supporting their
children monetarily mainly
many also said they're willing to pay
for major expenses of live
life events 75 percent of current or
future parents who responded to the
survey said they'd be willing to pay
for the child's college education 74
percent said they'd be willing to pay
for the child's wedding
49 said they'd be willing to pay for
child cell phone bill
44 said they pay for their child's rent
these are stats
27 believe children will be financially
cut off
after they've secured their first job 27
so one in four parents says
i'm no longer going to support them but
the other one is supporting pretty
intense by the way
on the standards how low it is according
to bank of america study
affluent respondents between the ages of
18 to 24 reportedly had in
investable assets that were between 50
to 150
000 to a million dollars while
respondents above the age of 25 had
investable assets between 100
two million dollars the three money
topics that were most taught
to the respondents were bargain shopping
sixty-five percent
saving money sixty-four percent writing
checks or balancing checkbooks
sixty percent i'll read this last one
here for those of you guys that like
stats like some of us do
i'm sorry adam but some popular money
management skill parents said they
want to teach their children include
handling credit cards and credit card
debt 92 percent
saving money for retirement and
investing 90 strategizing payments and
money habits when funds are low 89
and setting the budget 88 well yeah i
mean because there
there's there's the other story that
these millennials are living paycheck to
paycheck making a hundred thousand
dollars
i mean hello that's insane that means
they can't budget yeah and they're
saying i'm making yeah the whole uh uh
sixty percent of millennials earning
over a hundred thousand dollars right
now
saying they're living paycheck to
paycheck a business insider story
yeah how many of them are crazy how many
of them have their parents paying their
rent on top of it all or their cell
phone bill give me
let me let me ask you when you when you
when we were growing i'm just curious
you know like
you know yesterday i'm talking to we had
the greatest dinner last night with our
team we were at this uh state uh
house place and i had a board meeting i
had everybody read the book blue ocean
strategy
this is my home office exec it's the
best executive team we've ever had
this is i had all my c-suite executives
in at all my directors and everybody was
required to read the book
and give their we went through the whole
swot analysis and then at the end
you have to give blue ocean how can we
be a blue ocean and it was 10 hours of
purely ideation last night we went to
dinner
and we learned our controller uh uh
who is absolutely a ridiculous guy his
grandparents
owned gnc own gnc so one day his dad's
about to buy him a ram dodge ram his
that was 50 when he was born very
interesting story
and uh he used to be the president of
steel
com u.s steel company in new york so he
tells us that dad if you don't buy me
the brand new ram
i'm gonna join the marines he was 17
years old he threatens his dad
okay so his dad says okay son
no problem his dad goes to the marine
recruiting station
gets it signed as a father because he's
there yeah
he says here you go son you're off to
the marines in a month go do your thing
never call me back because that tells
him that he was so pissed off at the kid
never called me
he goes to the marines chris goes to the
marines
he serves he crushes it comes back
him and his wife they meet in a m
university they both go to school to
become accountants they're both both
accountants
they decide to eight years ago he learns
how to go and deal with horses so they
own 40 horses
they have like i don't know how many
cows they have 500 acres of land in
texas
and they make a boatload of money so
suspect i just so you know i'm your
director of fine i'm your controller
just for hobby because my main money i
make i make a lot of money
doing what i do with horses but last
time my cio david hayes
he says just so you know this is the
picture i had this the car i had when i
was in college
19 years old i said what is it brand new
porsche 911 oh
i said david get out he says yeah i said
were you spoiled yeah i said you being
sarcastic
no i was spoiled i said your parents
bought you a porsche and
he says yeah they bought me a brand new
puzzle what the hell is going on here
right
so how was it for you growing up and
what did your parents
take care and handle financially for you
once you became an adult 18 years old
what was yours what was you i'm curious
what did they help you with financially
at 18
after 18 after oh no i was cut off at
16.
seriously yeah what does cut off mean
explain customers like they give me no
money whatsoever
so the my mom handed me down
and so i got a scholarship in high
school
after 10th grade so 10th 11th 12th to go
to like the ritziest
private school in miami miami country
day there's country days all over the
country
i was a public school kid and i was
pretty good at sports i got a sports
scholarship all counting to this
high school and i went there and imagine
me
pulling up in the rust-colored honda
accord
uh a 1984 honda accord
like the poorest kid in the school yeah
yeah the color of russ my mom got in a
car accident that she gave me that car
and then
and then basically i had this car and uh
it basically was one of those cars where
the lights
yeah and the lights kind of open up oh
that's good but one of the lights didn't
open so one was like it was connolly
kind of like that
yeah so they carved the call blink yeah
one eye shut like tom cruise and um
that's what it is i would pull into
school in front with range rovers bmws
you know
the the the the nicest school in miami
16 did you have a job or no like how did
you make your money
i would uh outside of like with you yeah
i was not selling drugs at that point
i was in college but um but i would uh
if yeah if you pull up that that was my
but basically i was entrepreneurial
umpire baseball i would do a little side
hustles to make some money
love to see yeah i was uh
that's a track three wow like yeah
there's my car right there
but i'll tell you i'll tell you what
this did do
i'll tell you what they don't know why
you cannot procreate so
my parents did not teach me about money
my parents didn't give me any money
um i had to you know learn the value of
a dollar but imagine being this new kid
in school who shows up with this piece
of [ __ ] car
to the richest school in miami and by
the time i leave
high school i'm the captain of the
football team i'm the captain of the
basketball team i'm vote i'm voted
uh most humorous i'm voted most athletic
i basically said you can make fun of me
as much as you want
but i'll i'm willing to laugh with you
guys i'm going to kick some ass on life
no matter what exactly
yeah i want for all the ladies out there
who have taken notes
write all that down adam's procreation
resumes very
it's stout it's good but let me let me
let's before i turn it over to danielle
who's uh
very pro atom procreating i appreciate
that
hint the problem with school and and
sort of back to
everything that this article um
summarizes is that we all go to school
we all take the same useless classes
algebra biology chemistry trigonometry
wood shop even
but they don't teach you money classes
like they don't teach you again here
how to balance a budget how to you know
deal with debt credit cards
92 they don't teach you these skills
they teach you how to work
they teach you how to get a job but they
don't teach you what to do with the
money when you get the damn job
and that's the problem that's
essentially what this article is there's
a financial
illiteracy crisis in this country
absolutely but tell us about yours what
was yours like what was yours
when did your parents cut you off or did
they so
my first job out of first of all i had
my first job when i was 15 which adam
knows it
i lied on my on my job application my
first technical job i
i said i was 16 even though it was just
queen little caesars right here
and by the way no no car i had no car um
but
when i got out of business school it was
the first and last time i ever had debt
ever i had my student loans from getting
my mba
so i go off to wall street i turned i
turned down a job with arthur anderson
to become an accountant
and it was for more money and it was
they were going to put put me up in
corporate housing they were going to pay
for my last nine hours to sit for my cpa
and i'm like you know what i'm just not
a bean counter
i'm going off to wall street i'm going
to go in sales so
uh i get there i'm making so little
money that it covers my student loan
payment and my rent and that's it
so my mom is sending me a hundred
dollars a month to get my dry cleaning
out of hoc
so and but the minute i mean when i when
i
was probably nine months in what does
that sound by the way
you hear that sound okay probably when
i'm nine months in
nine whatever i i paid off my student
loans i got
i got a huge commitment that quickly
commission check and i well i was a rock
star
on wall street honey um so i mean i but
i wasn't captain of the football team
so well you could have been i feel like
you could be captain of whatever you
want to do in life
captain of your own show so she pays off
her debt nine months and she's
kicking ass on wall street so the minute
my mom turned 50
i paid it forward i flew her up to new
york
took her to a day at vidal sassoon we
had a blast
it was totally how old were you at that
time when that happened 27
27. how sick is that by the way let me
ask you yeah
and then i bought her a ranch outside of
a m you bought no joke
you like ranch dressing tried iola texas
google that it's it's you can't even
find it on a map so i know
i know i didn't buy ranch just so you
know when you were in
high school and you were before the
military i know that you had a you know
a 3.8 gpa
you were 40 000 in debt your dad paid it
off you you were a privileged child
extremely tell us tell us your story no
you know you have to realize i don't
even know what allowance is like you
know when people talk about allowance i
don't
know what a lot my mom's never given me
allowance like i'm telling you
never when i tell you never i'm not
kidding with you i've never gotten an
allowance i've had to make my own money
when we went to germany i learned how to
make my own money at 10 years old from
that moment on i was going to find a way
to get my hands on money
minus selling drugs never sold drugs
never sold anything uh illegal although
i come from a lineage of bootleg
of prohibition what do you call it
though
my uncle was one of them one of the best
he was one of the best
he was the best she was one of the best
he was the greatest bootlegger we've
ever seen
jfk's father was a bootlegger that's
right the kennedy family establishes yes
yes
so i uh i found a way to make money and
uh
in uh the first car i got was a 1979
honda accord
same as you except five years honda
accord that would only go drive
it wouldn't go reverse so we would have
to park my buddies
that would probably that's the one
that's the one right there yellow no no
right there no no go right there you you
had it
go back 79 you had it go right there top
left that's the one
that's the one i had yellow just like
that that was mine you're killing it
yeah i mean it was that's exactly the
car i had and
it got to a point where it wouldn't
drive past 35 miles and my dad and i had
to go drop it off to uh uh
we sold it for 500 bucks we're driving
out to a place to sell it i went from
glendale
all the way to upland on 118 and 210
freeway going 35 miles an hour and the
furthest line to the right just
visualize that i was so embarrassed
i'm like just don't see me you know your
flashers on yeah
but the point is say that again like
adam driving the go-kart
it's like adam driving a go-kart that's
that's a great visual
have you ever gotten a ticket for going
too slow i know you get tickets for
going too
fast yeah my honda accord could only
drive for a certain period of time
you know how you put the car in drive
yeah uh and
and you don't if you like i would step
on the gas pedal the car would shut off
so i drove home 30 miles why is it so
easy and i know that story i actually
yeah it was just i believe you so the
point is here's the point
i i i don't know the concept of
supporting at the levels of people being
supported today
right but also let me fly and they're
destroying their kids i also don't know
what it is
to be raised by parents who have access
to the resources that others don't
like i don't know what it is to be so so
say your last name is obama say your
last name is trump say your last name is
kennedy say your last name is vanderbilt
say your last name is gates or any of
that i don't know what it is to have
that last name either so
for to to be fair for both sides i don't
what do you do if you're a billion
dollars what do you do with the kids
there there's also that challenge
what do you do with your kids i mean
you're well off i mean you're going to
send your kids to nice schools you're
going to you know how you're going to
what do you do with your kids
there's an answer for this because okay
i've got a 17 year old and a 15 year old
who are at boarding school
so you put money on their debit card
and it's a once a month thing and when
they run out of the money
and they call you for extra before the
first of the month you say
i love you but i am sorry all right but
you're putting money on their cards
you're giving them
money or an allowance so what age what
age you're going to do then
you know probably through college
probably through college you'll do that
how much do they get a month
if you don't mind uh they they get a
hundred and fifty dollars a month
just so you guys know you don't have to
live here you're not hearing anything
now okay come come come
can you come listen to this come listen
to this come listen to this i wanna
speak i can hear you guys continue just
listen to what my i hear like there's
like three birds chirping in the
background
if it's just mine i'll work with it but
go ahead so you have a debit you have a
debit card
you need a padded room here so you have
a you've got terrorism because you guys
don't hear anything i'm good it's a
conspiracy theory
you give it to them the moment it runs
out they get nothing so the 17 year old
the 17 year old goes through it like
water
first few weeks i mean consistently he's
starting to learn
the 15 year old i mean this this kid is
frugal
and the rule is anything that's left
over at the end of the month gets swept
into a savings account
i love that system you know what other
system i think about i would do i i
would probably
so it's still making that noise okay so
here i'm not going cuckoo here the
sounds of birds alex
is hearing tweeting so so what i would
do what i would i'm gonna put it on and
i'll just
act as if there's two births right
behind me so what i would
what i would do is i would do a system
of matching
meaning at a certain age i'm gonna do a
match per
dollar you make i'll give you four
dollars and gradually it'll go down
so if you make five hundred dollars a
month guess what i'll give you
fifteen hundred dollars if you make uh a
thousand dollars a month i'm gonna give
you you know four thousand dollars three
thousand dollars
same in college in college it's going to
be a match match one like a 401k you
know how does that match
yeah i'm gonna do it like that so do you
bring money home buddy no problem here
you go
you bring two thousand i'll match you
two thousand you bring a thousand i'll
match you a thousand but you gotta bring
yours in as well positive reinforcement
and then eventually there's gonna be a
certain level of money set aside in an
account
they have a choice on what they want to
do with it and if you want to use that
money to buy a house
great if you want to use that money to
run a business great if you want to use
that money to go to college great
you have a certain set of money that
you're dealing with but it's it's a
involved situation not a
i'm just you got to do your part as well
now here's what i'm thinking
and what i'm understanding here is
because you got no money like you said
no allowance i don't get anything
planning for procreation yeah
i am um but you're using you're using
like clearly you're giving your kids
money 150 bucks a month
clearly you're willing to do something
for your kids but
with the with the with the understanding
that this is a lesson
this there's some learning going on here
you're going to learn how to save
you're going to learn to learn how to
budget you're going to get money because
you did things the right way
you're not just going to be gifted money
you're on my silverstone are my kids
silver
spoon fed with me how are they with me
even though these guys have a father
that can probably buy him a lot of
things is it a pretty low standard
kickback no they have to read
they have to do their shots there's a
there's a
two ends of the spectrum here set up
standards on what they got exactly you
do that we're gonna have a good time
together we'll have a great relationship
together if you don't
the bank is closed it's that simple
there is no bank i mean you you sat with
the tv
a broken tv for six months because
senator threw something at the tv
intentionally yeah intentions i'm
thinking this one
tv on a broken tv with a hole inside of
it i want you to watch those cards daddy
i don't like that hole next time don't
break your tv
right freaking so basically you're
you're willing to play you're willing to
give
them discipline and self-control i love
these guys man they're like my world
this morning i was late because i went
downstairs
and santa's like she goes she says daddy
homie
homie homie daddy she doesn't say hold
me she says homie
homie so i pick her up i'm calling so i
said how was your day in school
daddy school wasn't good why wasn't
school good
i don't like the swimming pool because i
don't like to swim in that pool why
don't you like to swim in that
chlorine hurts my eyes it hurts me i'm
like you freaking
[ __ ] you know she knows how to do it and
i'm talking to t co we're trying to
figure out where to put tico
like so tico what sport do you want to
take i want to take a comic book sport
class
i don't even know what that is listening
to joe biden infrastructure
it's a sport he says i want to take a
coding class where i can make
movies i'm like interesting so do you
want to take any like baseball football
basketball
no but you know what i wouldn't mind
taking a reading class where we all sit
together and read i'm like
freaking love this science that's why
he's going to be a scientist and then
dylan's like yeah i want to take
track to beat everybody yeah awesome
girls playing football basketball soccer
it's so interesting by the way one of
the best experiences we've ever had
is what our kids elementary school
public school was
we were assigned once a year a book to
read as a family
you sit down and read a book out loud
give a shout out to that school that's a
great school
armstrong elementary eagles private or
public public
get out of here this is texas yeah
fantastic like that's that's price
family reading oh that is
props man i mean you put that on twitter
i'll retweet it that's those are the
stories that
we got to get you on twitter more by the
way yeah i'm not that active on twitter
i tried i try to
our friend phil heath is like oh so
what's up bro we're going to hang out
all day then you're going to pretend you
don't follow me back on twitter
i go huh what phil heath you know who
we're talking about seven times mr
olympia
we hang out all day we have a great time
we go to him go to lunch
you know he's he's you know i don't want
to you know say anything
but he goes so we're going to hang out
all day you're going to act like i
didn't follow you on twitter not going
to follow me back i'm like
dude i swear you're not a guy you want
to piss off i know i go mr heath sitting
in the woods
i didn't see you uh yeah i don't even
check twitter i don't know i'm gonna
piss that guy off i don't know if you
want to piss that guy
okay so nasim taleb i don't know if you
like him or not have you read his book
black swan anti-fragile you know skin in
the game
he says if you want to go to page eight
adam page eight he says
bitcoin is worth zero and there's no
evidence that blockchain is a useful
technology
black swan author nassim taleb says this
is a business insider story
he also said there's no evidence that
blockchain is useful technology a new
paper tally laid out
four key arguments against
cryptocurrency bitcoin failed to satisfy
the notion of currency without
government in fact he said bitcoin
proved
to not even be a currency at all number
two bitcoin can neither be
a short nor long term store of value he
used the famous
juxtapose juxtaposition of gold versus
bitcoin which he said was poor
comparison
to illustrator's point and last final
two points
argued that bitcoin is not a reliable
inflation hedge
contrary to some analyst views and is
not a safe haven for investments whether
meant to protect against government
tyranny
or other catastrophes thoughts
do you agree or no are you more yes i
agree with them are you more no i don't
agree with that i'm more the market
agrees with him
the market agrees with them well last i
checked it was not exactly 65 000
anymore
look i'm gonna somebody who was here in
the office today
working with me earlier this morning
okay said danielle i want to thank you
i said why she said last time you were
here in florida you said
i understand everybody likes to own
cryptocurrencies
but take your take your cost basis off
the table and
just let your profits run that way if
anybody ever asks you
you can always say i never lost a penny
yep she's like you saved me
three thousand dollars and three
thousand dollars is a lot in my world
and i just want to thank you
because i just i let the profits run but
i took my cost basis off the table
thank you danielle and i said anything
for them for doing that by the way good
yeah cell discipline is very critical
can you explain what cost basis means
for somebody that's listening
you you put 500 into you bought you
spent 500
on [ __ ] on bitcoin yep and now it's
worth three thousand
so you take the 500 off that's right and
that way you say i never lost it that's
right
yeah if it was volatile fine if it was
speculative fine
whatever i'm good to go i didn't i
didn't lose a penny call it a day
and you you wake up you look at yours
you know she's not
an investor she's not going to follow a
bit she's not going to do the opposing
side one day
one day i woke up and it was like damn
it went from 65 to 30.
a lot of smart people are saying it's
going to get to a quarter million
dollars it's going to get two million
so what is more likely bitcoin to go to
one thousand or bitcoin to go to
a million dollars i would say one
thousand what are you gonna say
i think it's uh up up do you think it's
i don't know
you asked the question you asked the
question to danielle
am i more likely to agree or disagree
with nassim talib right here yeah well
i'm taking the disagree side okay so i
actually you interviewed pomp
yep anthony pompliano i had the
opportunity to go down to the bitcoin
conference and interview him a couple
weeks ago
smart guy sharp guy similar age we kind
of vibed
and this is the type of thing that i
think we need our
valuetainment someone like a pomp
pompliano debating this nasib talib
character
and let's find out what the actual truth
is right here because this is just
simply his opinion because
based on what he's saying here there's
hundreds of thousands of people
and and maybe even dozens of experts
let's say willing to debate
every single point he made and why he's
wrong like the fact that you can say
that
okay 99
quote-unquote um has not proven to what
does he say exactly
block is there's no evidence that
blockchain is useful technology here's
the debate that i'm i'm basically
bringing up
you constantly hear some of these
cryptos the dogecoins of the world or
the shimou enu's or whatever
maybe they're not here for the long stay
but you only hear that bitcoin's not
going anywhere
and blockchain technology is certainly
not going anywhere
and these smart contracts a genius guy
i'm sure he is his assessment's been
very accurate over the years
okay so for a guy like that to make a
comment you have to give him credence
this doesn't mean you have to agree with
him
but you have to give him credence on the
argument he's making i agree that's why
we're talking about him i agree
i want to pose a question to both of you
go forward let's look at the at the
chart yep
is bitcoin a store of value
the way you would think of a currency as
being some place you can store
value well i'll use like the the
the trending internet joke about
bitcoin to prove your point yeah my bit
i bought bitcoin i got it at 35 000.
yeah well now it's thirty one thousand
no it's forty eight thousand no it's
twenty two thousand
and the definition of store value is
something that stores value and and
stays at around the same rate right
table stability stable
so to to to be specific no it is not a
store of value however
let me just bring up one point and then
go back to you danielle if you said a
year ago
bitcoin went from 35 down to 33. oh my
god it went from six it's like it was at
less than ten thousand dollars yeah so
what are we talking about here it's
skyrocket over the last year
and the fact that it's having a bad few
months all right and i'm sure it'll have
a good few months in
a few months that's that's why they say
it's so violent so larry larry fink
is is basically blackrock i'm listening
to him on bloomberg
tv this morning he's basically
reiterating what nassim said
saying the same thing as well yeah and
blackrock i think they have like eight
trillion dollars aum they're ridiculous
they're blackrock is cream of the crop
yes yeah they're at the top so not to be
confused
with black stone yeah but but he here's
here's the thing that we have to also
realize as well and put some weight
behind it
i own a uh uh probably the best zion
williamson rookie card
okay and it's probably a card that's got
legs to be a five million dollar card in
the next 24 months
okay it's that it's that good of a card
zion
jumps 46 inches he's 285 pounds
he's 6'8 he's a beast he's a monster he
doesn't want to be a uh
uh uh a uh uh pelican anymore he's not
happy with the team
he just announced a couple days ago
which means he probably wants to be
traded to the next sooner rather than
later he wants to go out and run with
randall let's just say he wants to be a
nicky setter before
he goes there say he does something
special okay
that's a five million dollar card i want
to believe
this guy's going to dominate because i
have vested interest in him having an
incredible career right
but i also know that his body and his
style of play
could get him hurt to the point where
that card goes from whatever i
paid for 350 000 that card could go down
to 150 000
100 000 and i take a big hit right okay
so
a lot of people who are saying yes
bitcoin is this
of course it's there i have no clue what
they're talking about
they generally own bitcoin and a lot of
people that are saying
there's no way in the world bitcoins you
can there's no value that it has
they also probably don't own bitcoin
right
so you have to kind of know the the
people opinions is also
based on that exactly so the whole skin
in the game touche you know
with him writing a book ski in the game
so you have to also realize where people
are coming from so
i want to hear it from the people that
are in the middle who are not in that
say i think it's going
places or who are who are in you know
who are not in that are saying
you know uh uh who are in and are saying
i don't know if it's gonna go anywhere
i'm just in there hoping that if it does
i'll make some money on it but
i'm not a hundred percent sold on the uh
what's going to happen what's going to
happen with this
you know that's portfolio management 101
yeah if it's if it's speculative
if it's volatile then you limit it to
five percent there you go today yeah
mm-hmm let it ride so put it on red
there's a lot of smart people that are
doing five percent
oh i know yeah so there's a lot of
people so so for the people that are
bitcoin pro bitcoin and people that are
anti-bitcoin
a lot of smart people that are saying
look i don't know what's going to happen
with this quite honestly i'm not smart
enough to figure it out and none of us
are
we're going to keep a little bit of
money in there but not a lot and we'll
see what happens i mean
i did a whole bitcoin episode on
valuetainment economics and basically i
said here's my two cents here's the
bottom line
the big boys and the big girls in the in
the in wall street and uh you know
they're putting somewhere between three
and eight percent into the crypto world
okay
so let that be your guide if you're
going to put five percent of
your investment strategy into bitcoin or
into a crypto cool
you know you you know don't put in more
than you can lose when i go down to
these
to these like bitcoin conference a
couple weeks ago i asked the question
what percentage of your portfolio of all
your money is in crypto and you get
these answers where
ninety-five percent of all my money is
encrypted oh yeah even our friend gerard
here he says i'm
over leveraged to the t on crypto and
they know people where it's a 100 plus
where they've taken on debt to buy
bitcoin well that's an aggressive
situation
i mean you're talking about those are
believers those are believers they think
that
cryptocurrency is the future and you
cannot tell them otherwise and
if they're right they're the big winner
if they lose they're out i mean i think
it hasn't
i don't think it's been stress tested i
mean the only regulators that have
clamped down really are
the chinese it's not stress tested is
what you're saying no but not by
regulation in the united states
well we'll see what's going on
regulations if you're watching this
regulation's coming i mean if if gary
gensler can ever actually
get employees at the sec um because
there's so many unfilled positions then
you're watching this what do you think
smash thumbs up it's at 5 15 and 8 right
now
if you think we're going to see who the
audience is 5 15
if you if you think bitcoin is going to
get to a million first
smash thumbs up if you think bitcoin's
more likely to get to a thousand first
smash thumbs down i want to know the
rates of what our audience thinks so
we're at 5 15 to 8 right now
let's see what you think if you think
it's a million thumbs up if you think
a thousand thumbs down just curious okay
while we're doing that we'll go to the
next story here
with uh uh new york state
uh restaurant owner uh upstate new york
uh restaurant owner on chicken shortages
wing cost skyrocketed nearly 100 fox
business story wing shortage our latest
problem to plague
uh poultry producers who are who have
struggled to keep up with the demand
that have skyrocketed with the reopening
of the economy and due to a number of
fast food chains have recently
introduced chicken sandwiches
the lower mississippi based sanderson
farms inc the country's third largest
poultry producer said it does not have
enough supply to keep up with demand
despite recently picking up 40 million
pounds per year
last month joe anderson ceo of
sanderson's farms set up a goldman sachs
global staples form that his company
each week ends up
short 15 loads of wings for both retail
and food services the company plans to
allocate wings to make sure everybody
gets some
he said noting that the combination of
strong demand and limited supplies will
cause prices to climb
even higher from current levels danielle
and sanderson put itself up for sale is
that what it is
they did yeah i mean they're they're
striking while the iron's hot look
my my respect my hat's off to the guy
who like started a whole and
you will love this patrick there's a guy
who started a whole
company based on thighs dies thighs he
was he was interviewed yesterday he was
like look
wings wings used to be unloved we export
all of our thighs to the rest of the
world
damn it let's make thighs bring thighs
back we know the dark dark meat tastes
good
so he's trying to he's starting a whole
company based on make
thighs great again are you is it dies or
breaths i mean i'm a thigh guy i could
die
i'm not going to do it you know we were
going there you set us up i mean it was
unfair that was just too easy of a setup
right now so you're like you're you're
you're an equal opportunity
danielle as an economist as economists
we all respect is this just another case
example of supply and demand what is
this
it is an example of supply and demand i
mean look you had like
you had orange juice prices going
through the roof and then all of a
sudden
the weather forecast changed and then
they come down supply will
meet demand look at what's happened in
louisiana
in georgia you've got all these sawmills
up and running that hadn't been
up and running for a generation so all
of a sudden you've got lumber prices
coming down
because supply is coming on to meet the
demand
by the way on the on the uh on the ratio
of the bitcoin
yep it's 54 to 18. two thirds
66 percent believe 1 million 33 believe
1 000. we have
bitcoin is also perceived to be by a lot
of people who don't understand it
a simple refutation of fiat money
they're like
they're like they're driving the dollar
into the ground they're printing money
i've been told that bitcoin's a hedge
that's why i own it
and so for people who don't appreciate
the national debt clock for
a lot of them that's reason enough
with this wing thing just to get a
little recap i don't think that this
wing thing and the side thing and you're
a breast manner or a leg man
i think just just put it on it's not
that that big of a deal right now
because we're not in football season if
that's football season and there's no
wings
at your local wing at your local sports
bar now you're going to have a problem
it doesn't take so long to get a chicken
and if there's no hot dogs during
baseball season we got a problem
if there's no wings during football
season your analysis is amazing i'm just
letting you know
supply and demand baby you couldn't tell
he went to like the university of
michigan this is harvard right here
that's
harvard theory wherever you are whatever
you meet factory whatever's falling on
the floor they pick it back up and they
put it in a casing and they call it a
hybrid
why don't we why don't we bring some
team into it why don't we bring some
tame into and talk about victoria's
secret you know
i know this is this is an adam's story i
was in new york when that was like
the hottest ticket in the story
no the runway show fashion show oh yeah
the fashion show yeah
this this is an interesting interesting
victoria's secret abandons its scantly
dress angel
saying they're no longer culturally
relevant activists and entrepreneurs
will be the new faces of the brand that
says
business insider so the lingerie giant
said on wednesday that it was partnering
with a group of inspirational women
including activists and entrepreneurs to
promote a new brand image and shape its
around
these women who include the indian actor
and entrepreneur
priyanka chopra jonas and the pro soccer
player and gender equality activist
meghan rappano will become the
face will become the face and voice of
the brand victoria secret says in an
interview with new york times victoria
sector ceo martin
waters said the angels were not
culturally relevant in the late 90s and
2000 victoria's secrets runway show had
a powerful
role in the defined sexy most recently
it's been criticized
as outdated thoughts
okay going to say about this as well so
go ahead
kai is not a lady no i said you first
but i'm going to go to kaiser as a 22
year old seeing how upset he is
so look you're selling an image you're
selling a dream
this is an act of desperate fantasy you
are you're selling a fantasy
this is an act by a company whose
finances have pulled up
angels they're a victim of mall traffic
going down
they don't have a viable online it's
very hard to sell this stuff online you
kind of need to be in the store to try
it on
but malls are dying except for your your
nicest small so this to me this is an
act of desperation
adam is this catastrophic this is a big
deal guys this is probably the biggest
story in the world right now victoria's
secrets is not
they're they're going unsexy here be
careful with what you say right because
remember
the goal this is a big deal i mean look
at these lovely ladies right here
kai get ready use your fingertips here
and now type in
megan repino okay
this is where we're going ladies and
gentlemen we are now
going from the sexiest ladies on earth
to this lady i get it she's an athlete
respect she does some good stuff on the
field i do not want to see her on the
runway
not even a little bit okay she can do
her thing on the field
keep your ass off the runway megan so i
will say that i think priyanka chopra
jonas is pretty damn hot
wow i will say that this is sort of the
unsexification of america
this will mess up i think we might need
some justin timberlake to get infused to
bring sexy back because if they're we're
we're losing the angels for uh
soccer players this is the equivalent of
nike like um
victoria's secret's a pretty powerful
brand they're they're a sexy brand you
know women want to aspire to be sexy i
get it guys want to
get their women nice outfits for them to
look sexy you know we're bringing sexy
back jt
this is like nike saying you know what
we're not really going to use lebron
anymore we're not going to use
mj we're not going to use fantastic
athletes anymore out there
where do you see that fat guy over there
you see that john candy looking dude
over there
we're going to bring his ass over and
he's going to be the new face of nike
let's keep it sexy let's keep it sporty
and let's keep the women
who deserve to be on the runway on the
run who the hell thought this was a good
idea
like honestly the woke the whoa so let
me ask you a question let me ask you a
question so let's just say
let's flip it let's flip it and say
moving forward
calvin klein models are offending yeah
many many you just said that
and moving forward we need to bring
these guys with big bellies beer bellies
beer guts moving forward that's ronaldo
you mean ronaldo
offensive we shouldn't be doing that so
the current ceo by the way
go pull up to uh victoria's secret's a
founder
look what look is just put victoria's
secret and go to their uh wikipedia go
to the wikipedia
okay go to uh oh left go to wikipedia
uh papa papa go lower lower lower lower
lower until you find it
should be coming up here type in wiki uh
where the hell is it with computer okay
anyways go find it because you have to
see who the founder is
we can eventually get to it okay so look
at the founder uh roy raymond
click on roy raymond that's him he looks
like the founder victoria's secret yeah
okay
credit he looks like a guy that would
come out with something like that
okay so now here's what i want you to do
next i want you to now
go to the current ceo of victoria's
secret okay go to go to
go to the same uh wikipedia and then
type in that name right there
stuart yeah him right there okay copy
paste go somewhere this is what he looks
like
okay so you know extremely
conservative he was a former home depot
executive
okay he was a senior vice president of
finance for home depot
he was a senior director at pizza hut
before he was an
auditor and a manager and a cpa at
deloitte for six years so this guy was
an accountant he's a bean counter
become the ceo of a brand like freaking
victoria's secret
makes no sense to me it's it's it's as
if playboys
ceo all of a sudden becomes a former cfo
of uh you know pick a company there you
know
new york times i'm gonna go be the
playboy magazine moving forward what
we're gonna be doing is it's not fun to
be a bunny because a bunny is offensive
the animal we're gonna use as a donkey
right now instead of we're going to use
this right and the company that owns
victoria's secrets is a company called
l brands who is el branson that's what
i'm saying l brands is
their finances are in a shambles yeah
well they own a ton of uh retail clothes
yeah
what else do they got kai l brandon type
in l brands brands
bath and body works bed bath and beyond
pull up l brand's stock price
public by the way kai was supposed to
give his opinion on victoria's secret
let's let's
let's get kai involved here he's been in
a bad mood the last couple weeks
yeah because they're taking away the sex
what it is uh victoria's secret bunnies
makes a lot of
these they used to be angels out there
and now there's fact that's
this
it's very very what do you guys think
what do you guys think
are you david you can't you going to be
diplomatic here listen
um we hear the audio in the background
you're listening to it so you might want
to take the mic off yeah
vanessa you go it's just by the way
shout out to vanessa was just her
birthday
our extraordinary production what's your
opinion yeah did you have one or no
go ahead honestly there's like different
likes for everyone i don't really care
you don't really care
david what do you think i think
victoria's secret was that brand it was
that
sexy you know that's what it was and so
now to have it change
it's interesting i think it might just
be for attention maybe a little bit and
then it'll
be gonna go back to the same yeah like
what was it ihog from ihop
international house of burgers yeah what
do you think jokes uh so i think it's
interesting
by the way both of them should run for
office very difficult i got zero answers
you got no answers
give me a break interesting i'm gonna
hit that go ahead kai
all right uh so where's that where's the
no button i think it was the democrats
no that's not the
uh so for me i think what what's
interesting aspect of it is
that here it is they've always been one
extreme where it's been
skinnier the skinnier the better the
more unrealistic looking the better
that's kind of how things have gone
which now to what adam was saying with
the world culture it's kind of bouncing
back
but i think it's going the other
opposite extreme like there's
some uh dove and stuff stuff like that
in terms of their like the bosch soap
and stuff like that
they've they've landed a little bit more
in the middle where you have some
neutral ground where it's like you're
more
it's more realistic it's not as extreme
but you're also not now
going to complete other opposite i don't
see why an entrepreneur in sexy lingerie
is is the new like the news i gotta tell
you this story i gotta tell you a story
maybe i've told the story before but i
gotta tell you this it's so appropriate
right now i'm at harvard obm
uh what's it the owner president
management program the opm program it's
like three weeks you stay in harvard
right and one of my classmates is the
founder of this
victoria's secret lingerie company of
new zealand europe and australia
okay and he's killing it billionaires 7
000 employees
kicking us he's sitting right next to me
and he looks like the guy that would
start a victorious secret ask type of a
company
so at the end of it out of 164 students
eight of us are presenting
our ideas i'm one of them he's one of
them so he comes up and he said
so here's what i need i'm trying to
raise a half a billion dollars
and here's what my products are he shows
the products he says here's this product
here's that product
here's what we said this is our
best-selling product the whole you know
strings going down all this and he just
got some legit stuff
he says but to be and by the way very
monotone guy says but to be honest with
you this doesn't do its service
i think it's important for all you guys
to visually see what all this work looks
like
on somebody can i please have my helpers
show up
eight girls walk up at heart talking
about half
naked was running the whole show she
panicked she runs
market research here she runs around
takes her jack you guys can't do this
this is gonna be all over the news you
guys can't do this trying to cover these
girls this is harvard
and you see students are like we want to
see the product
product place we want to see the [ __ ]
touch and feel
and then he says he says so if you like
the product that's why i need a half a
billion invest with me he went off the
stage he ended up winning just because
he fooled everybody but i tell you
harvard was so
flippant nervous because of this whole
thing like oh my god
gosh god forbid so anyways i don't know
what direction they're going i don't
know what's going to happen
all i know is when you dramatically
change the philosophy
of your business and you dramatically
change your customer like you know
what's rule number one of business your
customer
you officially change your customer when
jerry springer went from his show
jerry springer says i don't want to be
this guy that's going around talking
about fights and people jumping on top
of each other
i'm a smart guy i was a former mayor of
cincinnati i have opinions
i want to be like more oprah winfrey
they went that direction
ratings disappeared catastrophically his
producer says
dude you're not oprah you are jerry
springer
you know he's the daddy he's not the
daddy that's who you are
because they knew their customer these
guys are screwing up not knowing who the
customers i don't know i just don't
think it's smart in a business sense let
me say
from a business perspective we all have
certain principles there's certain you
know truths in business
and number one is sex sells don't be
scared of that sex sells
number two stay in your lane you're the
sexy you're the sexy company or
victoria's secrets
sex sells stay sexy baby don't bring
sexy back keep staying sexy
man yeah last but not least hitting it
today stay sexy
and last but not least the riches are in
the niches so you're in the sexy
niche stay sexy baby that's all i'm
trying to say right we don't know one
thing
we you know how like with food when they
advertise what a burger looks like
for mcdonald's versus what it really
looks like yeah and you have like hot
wings or whatever yeah it's kind of like
instead of taking the picture of what it
what their commercials are they
just take it like uh when you open up a
frozen bag of wings and dump it on the
in in whatever bowl or something they
should just start advertising that
that's kind of what
they're running out of wings guys pull
up the logos real quick
a lot of you guys send the logos i want
to tell you we have it here we're
looking at it and if you can pull it up
kai what i want you to do next time
these are a bunch we need a logo for
this podcast what we need kai
is for you to put a number behind it
because like this no one can say top
right top left whatever so next time put
a number
and we'll come back to it and if anybody
else has a logo they want to post
share with us go on my twitter account
uh put hashtag pbd podcast pbd podcast
we're taking logos for the podcast and
the winner we're going to give you 500
we are still accepting it so kai let's
make sure we put some numbers behind
this here
are we doing podcast next week or no are
we on next tuesday nine o'clock
tuesday nine a.m back to the same
schedule as well folks if you enjoyed
danielle being here you want to see your
back click
that subscribe button and the thumbs up
take care everybody bye bye bye bye
happy birthday virginia
you